well it's not a review of stranger
things but it'll have to do for now the
defenders season 1 I assume they're
going to have another season so the
defenders is ultimately the Avengers of
the Netflix Marvel properties daredevil
Jessica Jones Luke Cage iron fist they
have all come together to stop the super
secret Patties from being you know bad
you've heard from stick that the fight
for new york is coming you've heard the
hand is going to make their move now the
hand is making their move now full
disclosure I watched half of Luke Cage
before I actually moved down to Los
Angeles kind of threw a wrench in my
time however I heard from a lot of
people that add a point Luke Cage you
can stop watching and it's fine I got to
about there so I was like alright I feel
like it's fine but to me Luke Cage
wasn't as good as Jessica Jones or
daredevil so when I heard iron fist just
straight-up wasn't good I felt like I
was watching some sort of decline so I
never actually watched iron fist and
that's one of the things I like about
the defenders as interwoven as it was -
iron fist story I never felt lost I feel
like they fill you in just fine in here
and I like the ensemble because
everybody has their different reasons
different motivations for being here
Luke Cage is straight up like I'm just a
good guy and I want to save lives and if
people are in danger it's my moral
obligations my responsibility to take
parts and we're going to fight these
guys
iron fist is like it's straight-up my
destiny it's my calling of course I need
to fight these guys
Daredevils a little more complicated he
does feel an urge a calling to be the
daredevil but after daredevil season 2
it looks like he has put the costume
aside it was a phase in his life that's
now over but like Batman in the Dark
Knight Returns he feels the fire burning
enemies like I'm daredevil let's stop
the hand Jessica Jones I'm straight up
like I'm not a hero
I don't give a about being a hero I
don't give a about these guys now
like before I'm chasing a trail for my
client and it's led me here so
everyone's different perspective and how
they view this situation is really what
makes the defenders fly for me also I
like Sigourney Weaver in here Sigourney
Weaver is the head of the hand she's the
big baddie and really you feel her
desperation she's desperate to succeed
at what they're trying to do was create
some tension among the ranks of the hand
but really I like the fact that they
have a villain who's not just like I'm
doing baddie thing for baddie reasons
because there's a comic book store and
well I'm that I do like the fact they
shave this season down to eight episodes
usually these Netflix Marvel properties
are about I believe it's 13
and every time I'm always like that
could have been 10 episodes that would
have been fine I hate it when shows draw
it out because of like we need to fill
the gap we need to fill up the time
somehow we need to puss up our season
this one doesn't feel so puffed up in
fact if it were a couple episodes more
could have gone for that if you're like
10 episodes that's the zone they should
hit for any of these Marvel Netflix
properties half the fighting in the
show's looks really great the other half
of the fighting was filmed in a dark
room with a bunch of close-ups and a
bunch of cuts which makes it feel like
they're trying to hide the stunt people
whenever that happened it just irritated
the on me I was like it looks like
TV fighting some of the other fighting
segments though or at least the shots
among the fighting scenes a long cut a
long pan it looks really good if they
could just do more of that for the next
time it'd be good it really does revolve
around Matt Murdock doe which makes
sense his seasons are the best of the
Netflix Marvel property he was the one
who started it out he's the most fleshed
out so they'll fill you in with iron
fist Luke Cage you get the gist you
don't need to see Jessica Jones but
daredevil seasons wanted to you should
however by the end of this season I feel
like the stakes that were so big near
the beginning the fizzled out by the end
right here I'm going to put a spoiler
warning I'm going to talk about the end
not like the very end but really the
villains the motivation the hand what
they're doing spoiler warning you've
been warned let's talk about it so
through daredevil stick has always been
like the hands coming the fight for New
York is upon I feel like oh the fight
for New York holy this hand is
going to make a straight-up big move and
while they do a big thing which is the
reason you should watch daredevil
because it ties into that I feel like by
the end there's no big fight for New
York is going down when you hear stick
talking in the daredevil series you're
like oh my gosh it's going to be like
reishi Algol and even in the beginning
of the defenders it starts out with an
earthquake you're like oh they're just
going to raise the city to the ground
they compare it to Pompeii you really
feel like Rickie al Ghul is going to
come in here and be like alright time
for New York to crumble and in the end
the crumbling of New York is possible
and they're willing to do it as a
byproduct to get what they want but in
the end they want to do it if they can't
open this door which by the end they do
open what's behind that door the elixir
of life essentially at the hand is
really old super super old again very
comparable to the League of Shadows and
I shall go but at that point it really
does diffuse a lot of the tension a lot
of the danger you have what you want in
the form of dinosaur bones or dragon
bones I know it's it's more important so
all these promises of the war for New
York is coming they're coming people are
in danger they're really
I mean the hand has had this elixir
harvested from these dragon bones all
their lives so worst case scenario the
hand gets this thing and everyone just
kind of lives the lives they've been
living granted they are super corrupt
people so it would be best if they
weren't around but if the defenders are
fighting for the well-being of the
citizens of New York they're not really
in danger that's how it felt for me
anyway just really diffused a lot of the
danger intention came down to a personal
thing where it's like we don't want you
to be immortal because we're the
defenders it's the danger of the hand
still destroying New York was a factor
it got buried under all the exposition
about them wanting their elixir of life
maybe the defender season one is not
this war for New York that we've been
hearing about maybe that's still to come
maybe this is a different thing
altogether is that the show isn't
clearing illustrating that fact so I
just got to assume this is it this is
their big move it doesn't ruin the show
for me it just made me go alright well
that's it I kind of understand so it
doesn't fear death
thank you for overreacting a little bit
stick eyes in the end the defenders was
actually a lot of fun you don't need to
watch all of the show's leading up to
the defenders you do need to watch the
daredevil season it's not the smoothest
ride what I like about daredevil is it's
a lawyer drama that happens to have
daredevil as the lead there's none of
that in here this is there is an
ensemble of Heroes that get together to
fight bad guys but it has a very human
bad guy or bad lady in the form of
Sigourney Weaver and some other things
that tie into Matt Murdock's life I
really liked all of that and well I want
to call this daredevil season 2 point 5
it is the defenders I will say check it
out it's 8 episodes not a hard watch at
all but all right guys the defenders
season 1 have you seen it what do you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]